The return of the Dilophosaurus and more Ian
Malcom and Maisie are just some of the scenes
we never got to see in Jurassic World: Fallen
Kingdom.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm revealing the top deleted scenes
from Jurassic World 2, plus explaining scenes
that were censored for graphic violence.
Spoilers ahead for the movie, so take care
if you haven't seen it yet.
Although Fallen Kingdom features more dinosaurs
than ever, there's one fan favourite that
ended up deleted from the final film.
Director J.A.
Bayona revealed a scene with a couple of Dilophosaurus
was cut from the movie.
The Dilo first appeared in the original Jurassic
Park and, let's face it, who can forget that
scene where Dennis Nedry gets his comeuppance?
It seems like the Dilophosaurus was supposed
to appear in Fallen Kingdom's opening scene
where the guy in the yellow jacket, who was
operating the mosasaur gate, was startled
by a rustling in the bushes along with a little
chirp reminiscent of the Dilo in the first
movie.
The merc's yellow jacket would also have made
the moment a nice call-back to Nedry's scene
in Jurassic Park.
The Raptor Chaser Twitter account snapped
some photos of a Dilo model at the Pinewood
workshop for the film.
I suspect the Dilos were cut to make the opening
scene tighter, keep the tension racked up,
and maintain the focus on the T-Rex about
to appear.
It's still a shame we never got to see this
rather colourful and interesting dino again
in the flesh, especially after the hologram
tease at the visitor centre in Jurassic World.
I don't know if any were taken off the island
as I didn't see any at Lockwood manor, but
given that Wu has collected samples of a variety
of dinos, it's not impossible that we'll see
Nedry's killer return in Jurassic World 3.
New to the Jurassic franchise is Daniella
Pineda's Zia, the paleo-vet who works with
Claire and Franklin at the Dinosaur Protection
Group.
And there's an interesting bit of backstory
about Zia that ended up cut from the movie.
Pineda revealed that she filmed a scene before
the main action on the island begins where
she's talking to Owen and says, "Yeah, square
jaw, good bone structure, tall, muscles […] I
don't date men, but if I did, it would be
you.
It would gross me out, but I'd do it."
Pineda says the scene wasn't relevant to the
overall story so was chopped as the movie
was running long, but it's also possible it
was cut because it didn't feel very funny
in the edit.
While the line feels like a potentially lazy
way for the screenwriters to point out that
her character is lesbian, the decision to
delete it is just the latest example of what
seems to be part of a trend in Hollywood blockbusters
where the reveal of an LGBTQ+ character's
sexuality is cut from the final movie, for
example, Valkyrie's bisexuality in Taika Waititi's
Thor: Ragnarok and Lando's pansexuality in
Solo: A Star Wars Story.
The initial cut of Jurassic World 2 was about
two and three quarter hours long so with the
final runtime clocking in at two hours and
eight minutes, there's more than half an hour
of footage we never got to see.
Bayona has said that right now there are no
plans to release any deleted or alternate
scenes on the Blu-ray or DVD, which will doubtless
disappoint many fans.
However, I've done a bit of detective work
and trawled through the official trailers,
TV spots and behind-the-scenes footage for
clues on what else seems to have been cut
from Fallen Kingdom.
First up is Ian Malcolm's line
"Here we are talking about dinosaurs again."
And they also seem to have deleted Malcolm's
classic line which he said in a teaser trailer
during the Senate Committee hearing.
"Life finds a way."
Maybe they cut this as they felt it was too
on the nose, but personally I would have loved
to have heard him say this again in the film.
Owen also had a couple of lines in the trailers
that were dropped from the final movie.
"This is gonna be awesome."
"Owen."
"Ventriloquist?"
"Stop it."
"You do love a dummy."
The dummy line should have been included because
it would have made Owen's ventriloquist question
to Claire in the movie funnier and less random.
There's a deleted jump scare in the island
control room when Franklin tries to fix a
lightbulb.
"Fixed it."
"Stop fixing things."
And I don't recall seeing this footage of
Maisie playing with dinosaur toys in Lockwood
Manor in the movie.
This would have been additional foreshadowing
of the reveal that Benjamin Lockwood had used
the dinosaur genetic cloning technology he
developed with John Hammond to create Maisie
as a clone of his dead daughter.
This camera angle and shot of the Carnotaurus
running at the gyrosphere wasn't in the movie
but there was an alternate take used of the
Carno readying itself to attack before Rexy
steps in and saves the day.
These trucks driving past a dino skeleton
didn't make it either.
And I don't think we saw this underwater shot
of the Mosasaur opening its eye.
Let me know if you spotted any other clips
that weren't in the movie.
The Jurassic films have always been pretty
intense monster movies; however, they've always
been accessible to a fairly wide audience
age-wise.
For Fallen Kingdom though, it appears that
some countries have actually censored a number
of the more violent scenes in the movie.
For example, the Indoraptor scene where the
dino rips off Ted Levine's arm was reportedly
censored in Italy and Korea.
Other scenes that have apparently been banned
are the scene of T-Rex eating the goat when
she's moved into the basement at Lockwood
Manor.
Also censored for some is the moment where
the villainous Eli Mills gets ripped in half
by T-Rex and Carnotaurus.
Even T-Rex's final roar in front of the lion
has reportedly been cut in some countries.
Now, do you think the Dilophosaurus should
have been in the film?
And are there any other deleted scenes you
wish had been included?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
Tap left to watch my Fallen Kingdom ending
and post-credits scene explained plus Jurassic
World 3 theory and tap right for my full movie
deleted scenes playlist.
Congratulations to my Solo giveaway winner.
Send me an email me from my channel's About
page or tweet me so I can send you the prize.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!